you
[Music]
[Music]
respect to Deshawn Watson's brilliant
dissection of opposing defenses this is
the most entertaining surgical procedure
when it comes to football baby
welcome to the B are betting show
presented by the Caesars Palace sports
book this is doctor quanti dr. Joffe
clusterer and on the resident goes cabby
Richards
she keeps stacking w's were you out on
the scoreboard yeah our best bet record
improve deprive in one after we cash
last week with the Vikings cabbie
I need more games like this they lend
wire to wire and covered with ease we've
now hit four best bets in a row I've got
another one coming right up let's go
Castro
[Music]
first off the marquee matchups of the
week everyone knows these are the most
intriguing games and you all want to
have action on them
Saints plus 4th the Bears total 37 and a
half all signs pointing to Chicago here
they're coming off a bye Travis Keys
back
Saints are without camara and cook put
Teddy Bridgewater and NFL best 27 and 7
against a spread and his career as a
starter and I love to bet on teams that
are peaking New Orleans is that team and
they peak every October 14 and 1 against
a spread in the last 15 October games I
like the Saints today headed over to
Sunday night the Eagles plus three at
the Cowboys total 49 and a half I know
it's been a rough couple weeks for the
Cowboys after that Jets lost their stock
is plummeting but you guys know I love
to buy low and sell high this is a buy
option here on the Dallas Cowboys who
are 12 and 2 against the spread versus
NFC East opponents the last three
seasons they've got both tackles back
Cobb and Cooper are back we talked about
this last week I think the Eagles are
just a tad bit overrated lay the short
number here with the home favorite and
the Cowboys Ravens plus 3 ATS the
Seahawks total 49 Russ is getting lots
of MVP love but do I love Seattle today
we're gonna have to wait to the end of
the show to find out let's quickly recap
the marquee matchups of the week I like
the Saints and the Cowboys and you're
gonna have to stick around for my pick
in the Ravens Seahawks game the peoples
parlay is coming off another losing week
and after six straight losses Kelly
to start the season it might be time to
rethink how we determine our picks
take a look fellas you've heard of the
proverb you give a man a fish to fish
which one of these team speaks to you
New York wins everything so Giants at a
victor everyday car what's the number
one pick for a reason Arizona Cardinals
because of yeah New York got bunch of
old people in a couple of young people
that's trying to have the old people
Chargers the tightness in Chargers all
day oh they're a mess this year too but
I believe in them beating the hell out
of the Titans that I can tell you how
coach are just if the Titans are just
issues Tennessee Titans the Chargers
yeah I'm gonna go with the Tigers man
yeah I'm gonna bring it back to Carolina
Thomas Davis s Carolina Panther legend
he's gonna bring it home for the lhr
just put your money down Thomas Davis
okay the third team is the Jacksonville
Jaguars at the Cincinnati Bengals if I
was gonna bet my money since I'm here in
Vegas bangles that's like a Unity game
let's do it no one loves us Jalen didn't
love us the team's gonna come together
in a blow mouth I guess I would lean
towards Jacksonville mangoes for sure
they have zero wins just like me
the Jaguars going with the Jaguars Matt
we're gonna go with the Jaguars because
the moustache guy sounds like a good
player it's a risky it's a risky look
but like so can football football can be
risky to go on with the Jaguars and
anonymous Romania I'm saving the beer
Marlys that if they win like Missy
Elliot once said I put my thing down I
flip it and reverse it so I'm gonna take
those worst advice
very famously told George and Seinfeld
if every instinct you have is wrong then
the opposite would have to be right the
people have chosen the Cardinals the
Chargers and the Jaguars so I'm going
with the opposite I'm going with the
Giants - three and a half the Titans -
two and a half and the Bengals plus five
Kelly what do you think of this taking
my advice and fading the people and I
kind of like this ticket I'm not gonna
lie finally yes I've been looking for
your approval for quite some time okay
no need for remixes top to bottom
Kelly's card is stacked
hooyah vacuum on that's right Kevin why
it's circled any of the games and the
people's partly I'm so happy you finally
listened to me and fate of the people
now let's get to more of my picks for
week 7 we're gonna start off with the
49ers - 10 at the Redskins total of 40
this is too many points to lay on the
road I know it's scary - back the
Redskins after that ugly ugly Miami game
this is a letdown spot for the 49ers
throw off that nice Rams win they play
the Panthers next I saw it on Twitter
it's simple math you guys San Fran beat
Cleveland and LA by a combined 41 points
and all you have to do is weight in on
the road against the lowly Redskins
false take the Redskins +10 Vikings -
two and a half at the Lions total of 43
we've talked about this before I do not
like to lay favorites on the road the
Vikings is the exception here we've
talked about my love affair with
coach Zimmer and his 80s promise and
that is what we're going back to the
well with this week this Green Bay
defense could not stop the Detroit Lions
last week in Lambeau but Minnesota can
do so Detroit one in eight against a
spread in their last nine is the
divisional home dog Vikings is the play
and on to Monday night we have the
Patriots minus ten at the Jets total of
43 I can hear the people on social media
now Kelly just get about the primetime
home dog or wrong I actually prefer the
under here bradying the offense is not
clicking they're just not what they used
to be this game reminds me of that
Thursday night
Giants New England game when three
defensive or special teams touchdowns
killed that total I like the under here
but if you do like the Jets the Patriots
just one in five cabby
and their last six at MetLife Stadium
those are my picks that doing with
defense is so scary having played
alongside future Hall of Famers Kevin
Durant James Harden and Steph Curry may
Robson knows a thing or two about he
checks but the biggest heater he ever
experienced or ever witnessed came from
a different teammate I'll let him
explain to you in this week's BR betting
I'm gonna be winding back in time I
think in my second year in the NBA
playing with the Knicks we have summer
league because Vegas part number one
time I had a teammate named Marty
Collins and one day we opposed to go out
to the club have a good time and we were
like all right our girls are getting
ready upstairs they were taking forever
so we went downstairs to go try to go on
the tables I remember finding this
hunted on the chip and I gave him out of
here broke plates and he went on the
roulette playing all his different
numbers all his family's numbers
birthday numbers just kids numbers and
girl his number and I watched this man
literally over 20 minutes win $100,000
and like when I say we were yelling and
celebrate like we were in a game
jumping fist bump and screaming and what
we came back with the money they were
like there's no reason to go out to the
club before we got everything we need
right here it's funny could my friend
gave me like ten thousand just so I was
just there to support it's pretty cool
like Jesus congratulate my life
[Music]
I wonder if they took that hunter grant
to the club the following night what a
party thank you very much Nate Robinson
for joining us on the be our bedding
confessional
listen when Twitter is of blowing up her
dm's like Jose Altuve in the ninth
inning there are some actual insightful
questions from the blue to report
audience these are the minds of the
public be more b22 wants to know why
does adding a Pro Bowl player or losing
one other than the quarterback not
affect the line Kelly we actually have a
great example of this we saw the Rams
defensive player Jalen Ramsey I'm sorry
the Jaguars offensive player Jalen
Ramsey get traded to the Rams this week
and neither line moved because of it now
some of that could be due to public
perception but in reality it's not it's
because Jalen Ramsey just isn't worth
any points for the betting line similar
to where a Patrick mahomes would be and
the reason why is because hey he's
starting with the new team he has a lot
of system to learn and while I do think
he's going to be a beast with Aaron Don
darn 'old in that backfield this is just
not gonna move the line it the public
perception says hey I'm gonna bet the
Rams of sweet because Jalen Rams is
playing and probably the Falcons is the
play over 10 32 s how badly do you think
Patrick mahomes the actions will affect
the amount of money that gets better on
Chiefs games obviously affect a lot yeah
you're correct it's gonna affect the
lines obviously because mahomes temor is
a significant drop but actually Matt
Moore served as a serviceable
quarterback on Thursday night against
the Broncos
it looks like mahomes we're hearing is
gonna miss maybe three maybe four games
their next four opponents though I do
think are still gonna get tons of action
they're playing the Green Bay Packers
Minnesota which I like both of those in
following weeks and then they're playing
the Titans and the Chargers Chiefs money
will come in on those games
Troi mcwhat McKnight asks what's your
process for analyzing and selecting your
underdog cat candidates for football
season yeah you guys know I love the
underdogs
38:54 and one straight up the season I
know that doesn't sound like a winning
proposition but if you bet $100 on every
dog on the money I need to have almost
1,500 bucks in the season now it is
easier to analyze the dogs in college
football than in NFL but matchups trends
injuries home-field advantage all comes
in me finding those outright underdogs
all right here is the situation she's
been on fire in the past month with her
best backs
let's make it five in a row Kelly let's
go last week again with the Vikings -
three and a half later now 5 and 1 on
the season the moment you guys caught me
waiting for my best bet of the week is
the Baltimore Ravens Plus 3 cabbie and
Vegas is ready to give Russell Wilson
the MVP but not so fast that's right
Seattle will have the last 5 once just
by 4 points or less we're getting points
with the better defense in the most
mobile quarterback in the game Reagan's
Plus 3 don't forget to spring a little
bit on that money line all right guys
let's recap all of my picks for week 7
these are listening order of confidence
on how many units I would recommend you
bet on each we've got a four unit play
on the Ravens three units on the Vikings
and three units on the Pats Jets
remember a unit is a standard bet amount
it should be 1% of your bankroll I've
also got two units on the Saints cowboys
and Redskins thank you at home and thank
you on your phones for joining us on the
B are betting show presented by the
Caesars Palace sports book follow our
football journey on social BR underscore
Benny good luck on all of your bets and
cares so profit is Sunday
[Music]
[Music]